would you guys rather have a girl that
was a nine and looks like one of the
baddest chicks you've ever seen in your
life okay
but
but
but she's got an only fans or a girl
that's like a six
what are we doing on this one
[Music]
she's not sleeping with anyone else but
it's sexual content what like is she in
a like any type or is unique
yeah everyone like
so you take the sex if she if she wears
like a balaclava or something
but the name is
i ain't ever getting married first unit
but at six is like a six is like one
above me bro it's one of them
so that means you can you can probably
deal with it
she has time to grow up
i just think with the family
that's what i'm saying like that but you
know parents you know when you get to
know someone they want to know
everything about you
you know what it is your little sister
could even find it mom look at her very
long
i'm the only child
you even have to go to the internet
you're playing the game in your business
all it takes is
you're done
but i don't know man
looks could could get better though i
know some people that have glowed up and
look amazing i think that's like a lie
that girls tell each other like
i don't know
even guys
i think some girls glow up maybe like on
instagram but like in person you still
see like you can you can you can see
girls
filters you just got better doing makeup
yeah it became picasso like there isn't
this and the angles are not bro
like you know if you survey men from
like 20 to 80 years old you know what
age they find the most attractive 20 i'm
saying 25 to 50. i'm going to say 20.
yeah it's like it's like um i think it's
22 23. i told you i'm sorry
yeah
okay
so you you get like some girls that
maybe get some work done but i just
think like i don't know in person like
their face looks weird to me a lot of
the time
yeah like that like the the botox eyes
like the
the non-facial expressions yeah yeah
you know when they can't they can't move
their face properly oh you're struggling
though is that
what qualities do you guys look for in a
wife like a
or a long-term girlfriend you guys are
young oh god oh adam what
yeah
what was that she has to be nine she has
to have a kid
no that doesn't
that's not brave that's stupid
no i'm going to do that
to take on a child is a lot you know
that's i mean
i wouldn't do that right now
but like if that situation
consider it in the future it depends on
the relationship i have with to go but
of course you shouldn't don't do that
but it's my life maybe you can but i
just think it's not wise
who determines whether it's not what
like that's that's what's just like
society
if it's wise or people's opinions it's
not people's opinions it can be backed
up by data you have to get freedom you
you have to live care i mean i think
that's fine if you want to live carefree
but i don't think that results in long
happy marriages
i know
like do you think that's conducive for
building families
it can't work i've seen i've seen that
i've seen it within my family i think it
depends on upbringing too
like you have to be able to be like
exposed to co-parenting and seeing
broken families to know what works for
you and what doesn't work for you kind
of depends on how open you are yeah
okay if you're if you're quite
close-minded to certain things and
you're not really gonna
one go 100 in for something so then
there's no point dude no i just go go
and make sure the kids are right in it
so
so so let's say you marry you marry a
single mom okay
you date her for 10 years okay then you
guys break up
why
so why because that happens it's like
the average after you get married no
after you get married the average like
um age of divorce or the average time it
takes to get divorced just like eight
years so let's say you get there when
it's like the kids won you leave when
it's nine you have no rights to that
child none
but that's your child though no i know
but you like like i've heard horror
stories of men that like they raised
these children and then it doesn't work
out with the mom she doesn't want
anything to do with him now they have no
rights to that kid that's what i mean
when i say it's not wise
that's just a risk you take i don't
think anyone's going to go into the
situation thinking this isn't going to
work in 10 years then what happens if
this right but there's but there's
things you can do to lower your your
risk take risk and prosper i think like
but why
well why why do it when you don't have
to because let's be real you don't know
what the future is going to bring so
when you're in the moment you're
thinking yeah everything's going to be
all right if everything's going to be
good
and then the future comes and then it
doesn't go to plan there's a lot of
instances where that is your child and
10 years down the line it doesn't work
whatever now mum's got full custody you
know you're in square one with the other
guy that's not even his child as well so
a lot of things it's not as plain and
simple just saying
let's limp like let's limit the risk
like it's not as easy as that because
there's still times where you can limit
risks but then
it still happens you get so
not everything is in your control
sometimes because anything can happen
that's why well but but that but that
that is in your control who you date
that's like the number one
like yeah it is
no but
in control of the situation that happens
yeah in 10 years let's say you break up
like you can't control that because you
can't see yourself from now in 10 years
divorcing the girl because in that
moment you're thinking yeah this is
someone i'm going to be with for the
rest of my life
and then as the 10 years is creeping up
things are just going left like there's
no point already preparing for exactly
like and it's like you're trying to fix
it but maybe it's just not fixable and
then you just get to that 10-year mark
and then boom like
essentially if you want to eliminate
exactly that yeah that's fat it's good
you can have you can have your own
family
break up with your mom after 10 years
and then obviously like the kid might
not want to talk to you or anything even
though it's your kid the kid might not
want to talk to you but you still have
rights in court yeah he's not it's
definitely not favored towards men
that's true you have rights in court but
you would know if the kid wants to be
with you or not because there's so many
kids that say no i don't want to go to
my dad's house like no like please don't
make me go there even like really i know
a lot of crazy moms yeah
it's true but it's like after that after
you've gone through that you're telling
me you wouldn't date another single
woman like i mean a single mom
makes no difference it's no difference
really it's just wow this is really
interesting this is the first group of
guys that i've ever had on here that's
like yeah i would date a single mom
there's nothing really that's wrong
like
i would would you would you what's my
point for me personally i would date one
whether i'm going to go to marry the
dirt i don't know yeah we don't know
exactly but to date one just off the rip
date come on bro
would you would you want your brothers
to date a single mom would you have no
do you have brothers no no you have no
brothers
all sisters wow yeah but i mean what
about the close close male friend yeah
wood
so i just i think it's it's baby mama
drama that i don't like that's right
that's right
if your baby mama's giving drama
knock it off what what is drama though
what like what do you mean like girl's
dressed it's like oh why are you out
with her
well because girls girls are at least a
hormone during sex or no so during sex
and when they have a kid so when you
have a kid with someone you like release
a hormone that makes you like bond with
them right so you're you're very much
attached to someone you have a child
with gosh
men release a hormone during sex that
makes them like territorial over a girl
yeah that they've slept with that's why
i've heard guys like say like they'll
sleep with a girl and they like don't
want to date her or care about her but
they still like don't like her
like moving on because they're like
territorial
i know that i feel that yeah i feel that
scary i feel
like what is that you guys just feel
like yo she can't do nothing
it's just it's
you want to go do your thing but you
don't want to see her move on oh yeah
[ __ ]
this is this is how you get like girls
like fighting each other over a guy you
know
no
no no some girls are just crazy some
girls actually
i don't think i could ever do something
like that like fight over a guy yeah i
just feel like if you have that other
option bro that that's yours
no i wouldn't either like
like
let him go yeah it's not worth the fight
no not but i feel like that's why
because it got
focused
don't try this no
okay um
i'm